jingle bell rocks oh movie Jingle hello  Jingle Bell Rock witch didn't bring you  back to Mean Girls  it did yeah I mean there are days that  bring it back to Mean Girls like October  3rd like of course is always around me  of course on Wednesdays we were pink all  of it that movie is so iconic and  quotable non-stop I mean did you know  when you were making it like this is  going to be a thing I don't think we  knew I was just talking to Amanda  Seyfried the other day about this and we  were like we didn't know really when we  were doing it because we were all having  a lot of fun on set and then when it  happened it was just such a phenomenon  from it well I watched it three thousand  times so thank you